Now, that last task may have been a bit harder than the previous ones.
This will be our last requirements change,
so let's take a few minutes to reflect on the difficulty of this last step.
I have the same question as I have had before.
How hard was this step for you?
How do you feel about your code?
And how many clicks do you think your cats have gotten?
Additionally, I'd like you to reflect on your solution for this project.
Are you happy with it?
Are there problems that you can foresee with it?
What would happen if I asked you for more changes?
Does your code feel brittle or flexible?
Simple or complicated?
After this reflection, we'll start to get more serious and
we'll talk about solutions.
I'll reveal how I organized my code for the project, and we'll start
moving towards becoming professionals in our code organizational techniques.